- All right, we always close out
with good news to end the
shows and today's is delicious.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
Our next guest is a friend of the show
and Food Network star who owns
a wildly successful bakery
and has a slew of cookbooks.
In fact, he has a new one out now
called "Super Good Cookies for Kids".
And we have him on the line right now
to tell us all about it.
Everybody say hi to Duff Goldman.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Hi, Duff.
- [Duff] Hey, everybody.
- [Kelly] What's up Duff?
So it's great to see you as always.
So before we talk, wait
I hear that you're now
getting into acting.
Is this true?
- (laughs) Yeah, so, there's
a movie, it's on Food Network
and streaming on Discovery Plus,
it's called "Gingerbread Christmas".
And it's basically the story
of a woman who comes back
to her small town from New York,
and, uh, she's trying to
save her family's bakery
by entering into a gingerbread
decorating competition.
I play, this is kind of a stretch for me,
so I'm not sure if I pull this off,
but I play the judge of
the baking competition.
- [Kelly] What?
- Which is not familiar territory for me.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So I gotta, you know,
hopefully I do a good job.
- You really had to take a deep dive,
go real method on that.
So, tell us more about the new book.
- So, the new book is "Super
Good Cookies for Kids".
It's actually a follow-up to my last book
which was "Super Good Baking for Kids".
This one I really wanted
to focus on cookies.
Uh, for or a couple reasons,
one, I find that cookies
are a great vehicle
to get people excited about baking.
There's not a lot of
ingredients in most of 'em
and you can do it the first time
and get a pretty good cookie,
but then you can spend
the rest of your life
getting better at it, which I really love.
That's what I love about cookies.
And that's why cookies that
Grandma makes are never as good,
or, are always better than
the cookies that like,
a professional pastry chef makes.
They've been doing it forever.
They just understand how
to make delicious cookies.
- Yeah. Who doesn't love a cookie?
Well, you are nice enough
to send over one of your favorites.
So, wait, what is this? Thank you, Justin.
This is beautiful.
- Thank you. Those are super simple.
Those are rainbow meringues,
'cause I love everything like, unicorn,
and rainbow, and sprinkles,
and bright, and fun, and silly.
So you make a meringue, you pipe 'em out,
or you make a meringue,
and then what you do is
you take the food coloring,
and you paint the inside
of the piping bag.
Then you put the meringue in
there and when you pipe it out,
it comes out all rainbow
streaked and really cool.
Kids love this recipe.
It's really, really, really cool.
- Thank you so much, Duff,
for making this easier for us parents.
This is cool.
I'm liking your post
now, I already like you.
And all of you watching remember to pick-
- [Duff] I miss you!
- I miss you too. I know.
Next time I'm gonna give you
an awkward long hug in studio.
And all of you watching,
remember to pick up a copy
of "Super Good Cookies for
Kids" in stores right now.
But, often at this point in the show,
we give our guest $1000, thanks
to our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show".
But an author, baker, TV
host, an actor like Duff, is,
he's got food in his pantry, y'all.
He's fine. He doesn't need money.
So today, the money's going
to an audience member.
So everybody check under your seat,
and see if you're the winner of $1000.
(trumpets sounding)
- [Kelly] You have no faith it's you.
Yeah!
You win for best response.
- [Audience Member] I'm
your biggest fan, I'm sorry.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I love you so much, so this is crazy.
- [Kelly] I love you so much for your-
- He was gonna take my seat, but-
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I love you.
- I love you so much.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's so nice.
- You're so personable.
Your voice is amazing.
(audience cheering) (Kelly laughing)
Yes, Kelly. This is amazing.
- [Kelly] Wait, wait. I love you for this.
I love the compliments, but
this moment is about you.
So what are you gonna do
with that thousand dollars?
- Well, we are content creators,
and we have a show coming out on TikTok.
We are creating content constantly.
It's coming out in the new year, 2023.
- [Kelly] What's this show?
- It's called DeLoach and
Jean. It'll be out 2023.
What's your Tiktok, babe?
- [Audience member In brown
hat] Dave underscore Bays.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
I'm gonna have y'all back
whenever you launch your-
- [Audience Member]
Yes, please have us back
when we do like, more of the show.
- Yeah.
- But like, this is so freaking crazy.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I'm so-
- And we love you, Kelly.
- [Kelly] happy for y'all.
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Well, use that
money to create some content,
or have some fun with it.
Thank you so much for the compliments.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- You made me feel good.
Yeah, $1000. Bur bur bur.
- [Audience Member] Thank you!
- [Kelly] Thank you so much
to all our guests today.
JB Smooth, Aimee Garcia, Fran,
Max, Courtney Marie Andrews,
and Lawrence Zarian,
y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, make a
cookie, turn it around.